hi christina how are you doing good
thanks
i appreciate you talking to me about
this i love the adams family i have so
much fun with these movies
and i'm curious how do you channel your
inner uncle fester is there anything
that you do to immediately get back to
his voice and his mindset
you know i i think i
until i had my own child i was the uncle
fester to my own family uh i have a ton
of nieces and nephews and so
uh i was the weird uh single uncle for a
long time uh so i really just try to
channel that um
and i have a lot of eczema and i feel
like fester probably has a ton of eczema
so i just uh i think about myself
getting out of the shower piping red uh
my skin on fire and i feel like that
really brings me into the the vibe and
mindset of an uncle fester
what do you most enjoy about the journey
that he gets to take in this film and
how he gets to save the day a little bit
you know uh
the it it's a out of family two is
really a road trip movie um but inside
of that uncle fester um wednesday has
been doing a science experiment where
she
um has decided to try to make uncle
fester smarter by merging his dna with
an octopus um because that will make him
smarter um so he's under this constant
physical transformation uh which is a a
fun thing to play just beyond you know
trying to say funny words or or you know
funny scenarios this weird physical
thing is happening to him uh he's also
giving pogba a ton of dating advice and
i don't believe he's ever been on a
second date so i don't know if anybody
should be taking dating advice from
uncle fester um so uh you know i can
relate to a lot of that um and uh so he
it's i just love when
my characters are specifically something
like uncle fester has active things
happening to him uh and that he is
acting upon that's like all you're
asking for is a performer so there's a
lot of that in here for me to play with
does that also change your physicality
when you're voicing him even if we can't
see it does it change how you stand and
how you
want to voice him
um yeah i mean
fester has a lot of action in this movie
and so
um trying to do trying to voice action
is a weird
uh thing that you have to learn how to
do of like
you know there's a lot of sort of like
that like oh you know he's like gets
bumped around and knocked around and so
that that takes a little while to figure
out and um
especially the further you get into the
animation once they have
either animatics or the final you know
as they're getting towards the end of it
um and
it it helps to be able to visually see
it and then i can sometimes watch it and
and do some of the uh
the more active elements once i've seen
it because i can i have a better
understanding of what they're going for
i know that you've previously said that
you grew up watching the addams family
tv series and that you've watched the
movies that came out later
what was your first impression seeing
this family this creepy and kooky
family what did you make of them when
you first saw them well i think like you
don't is when i was a kid and and
you know when i was a kid watching
reruns of the tv show and then and then
later watching the adams family values
live-action movies
what i don't think you realize is one of
the reasons they're so successful is
because
they are a family like any other and yes
they're weird and disgusting and creepy
and kooky but ultimately they're just a
family who spends a lot of time together
and has issues with each other but
there's something very ultimately
relatable about them as weird as they
are also i think the feeling that
you feel like your family is
always an outsider and yet also
completely normal um which is a weird
juxtaposition but i think a lot of
people have can hold both of those
feelings at once and i think the adams
family
really speaks to that those feelings um
so
uh all of those i think make it just
incredibly relatable group of people as
weird as they are
on a very different note i very much
enjoyed your performances at growl and
poe and dickinson
what was it like to take on that role
how was the experience of embodying
embodying someone like that
uh it was a blast i mean i think that
show's so well done um
you know haley's a tremendous actor and
and the team the creative team behind it
has really created something really
special and unique um when they offered
me edgar allan poe my friend io debris
who had been as a writer on big mouth
and now voices missy as well had written
the episode so it was kind of a
no-brainer to go on and play what was
interesting at the last minute they were
like you know edgar allan poe is
actually kind of southern she able to do
his southern accent and i was like okay
you know so at the last minute it became
sort of
uh
a bit of a southern uh uh accent um
uh so i i hope that i was able to pull
that off uh last minute um but i i think
the show is so
uh the tonally it's got such an
interesting vibe to it and um you know
this mix of of classic uh literature
with a very modern take is is a fun
new development in in in storytelling
that that i was happy to really excited
to be a part of it was so fun it was
such a fun performance so i appreciate
you talking to me about that and about
this i love the adams family so thank
you right now thanks for having me